okay let's see what we can do in this
game welcome to this video metabolics
dope so Keith Indiana that's generally
good news at least if they don't know
that line well and i keep getting good
positions okay not be seven it's not
seen so often yeah i'm happy that i have
provoked each six it's usually quite
helpful to do
yeah you know it's h4 right here and I
keep asking myself those questions even
though I've played this line really
often okay that is not very threatening
but do I go h5 or g5 I think I'll go h5
here okay that might be might get very
nice if he somehow can play b5 now then
he has some play otherwise you might be
five and strategically speaking wide as
winning or Bishop b5 who ok I'll go 95
Bishop b5 he had the trade and 93 so
okay i'm getting what do i do here you
want to build blunder into some stupid
tactic at the position is very good for
white because black has absolutely zero
counterplay i can get to a 5 while you
cannot get to air form and the C file is
open already he currently has it yep
plucked with that night on c5 but this
is something that should not be a
constant feature of the position it
should be something that I can fight
against okay tries to trade with 97 them
reinforcing here if for interesting hmm
not sure that it helps as a force now
closer closer to my control
it was the wrong way to phrase it but
what I'm trying to say is that is this
is within reach now a4 ok I'm going here
now probably you won't take rook a five
or something like that is more likely
okay he did take I Scott she's got the
hook a five still maybe
I wonder night a three or C 3 I think 9
a-3 yeah so now i have night C toon
let's eat you to be four but peroxy
won't first and can start with Roxy one
the trade of the light squared Bishop
also assured me of that f5 square which
can be very handy ok
I wonder what the best way to do it is
not so easy maybe also we should be to
93 years also very tempting to get the
Knight to f5 and at the same time
prevent any be form it's not totally
clear how much this how useful the night
is it's hard too hard to believe that it
can be badly placed but it might look
better than it that it actually is we'll
see okay probably here and doubling on
the c4
Jack looks nice but how r to win this is
often a problem before before might be
helpful oh just
okay I think you have to do this ok I
can take on c5 and go 93 I probably have
Tim didn't see any other way forward I
have to cover the Queen
so now loop takes you five becomes
possible ok I can take the rook I can
take the Queen I take the Queen I think
I'll take the Queen and now there's this
this check down when I have nine f5 it
that the bishop doesn't come to deform
or about me can come to you forward it's
not a problem I can take yeah yeah I can
take this one I didn't see it oops
wow that means i did not see at all
shoot and now we can actually take what
am I playing yeah wow wow time warner
I'm such an idiot sometimes sometimes I
really think I should really switch to
some different gaming how can I overlook
that please how is that possible amazing
maybe it's still not losing look before
Bishop e3 I don't believe it midnight c4
somehow maybe like this maybe I'm not
losing wow I was extremely lucky black
forfeit fun time chairman now that was
i'm looking now Bishop takes a three
yeah the whole game was kind of okay Amy
white Adam that set from from here White
has a clearly better position it's close
to a strategic win it's it's it's
difficult to to convert totally
convincing me but it's very nice as why
this dominating on the queenside is f5
and so on John maybe night before c6 is
even more effective I don't know I
couldn't really tell I was too tempted
by the night coming to f5 and I really
don't think this was was bad or anything
so what is this here I mean this should
just win not nothing more nothing less
what does when rooks is six wins so this
is nautical this is not great I didn't
see the bishop coming to see 5 which is
very embarrassing this wins there should
be six king it to and night c4 next and
it's over that's why it starts to pick
up pawns engine is on plus form yeah I
just win win the house this this is this
is all falling just a better version of
the game essentially but this also
should be good just start look-see for
ya what is what's what's what's on your
hook a1 given by the comp
you have to have to redo BAM by bring
the night around me to c3 to take a 4-2
c6 computer gives this line I mean let's
just see what what happens in the in the
engine line look see one then bring the
night over namo black black and I'll
take this is the thing I am now here I'm
just winning stuff you cannot defend all
this and this this king of aid and now i
can play whoopsie form yeah as this is
not a problem anymore near the a pond
move in here yeah this is just
embarrassing but at least it's not using
it was lucky I was really lucky in fact
I'm winning here still with exactly what
I played but I didn't didn't see it
obviously I just blundered rook takes a
three a bishop takes a three so I
probably should have just deservedly
lose the game okay thanks for watching